it's Wednesday at 6 o'clock the autumn
sunrise lights on Westminster today top
story and please take control this is
all our politics live from Westminster
as MPs vote to take back control of
parliament
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
very well this government will take this
country out of the European Union on
October 30
in our ladies the surrender bill
currently being proposed by the leader
of the Opposition I really failed to see
how I can be accused of undermining
negotiations because no negotiations are
taking place
when will the Prime Minister finally
apologized for his derogatory and racism
or okay so what happened we are the
laughingstock of the world just look at
the international press that's the
European press we are phenomena case
written now we look like the worst
Banana Republic you've ever come across
what would you say believe it there we
haven't talked about my book at all how
much you enjoyed reading it over
you haven't said how much you haven't
sent me a free copy Oh typical labor you
haven't sent me a free copy that's all
you need to know you can tell me that
you can tell from his lack of not
understanding of Parliament that he's
not read my book about Parliament oh
good I'm happy but you're wealthier than
I am true good evening as Westar braces
itself for another night of drama in the
desperate power struggles going on in
the place behind me here
yeah we're gonna go back the cards or
the book eyes to the right 329 the nose
to the left 300 what's going on here
his MPs are clear and agreed on the
opposition benches out those
conservative rebels indeed that the
priority is to pass this bill to block a
No Deal exits on October the 31st and
they want it and they want it done by
Monday the pierogi well it could happen
by Friday why because it's a push
relation right so then straight after
the so then there is now a debate about
an election
but these amendments are in my view
mostly taught and a waste of time we can
create you on that caste it's a live on
air how many more to come do we know the
eyes to the right 327 the nose to the
left
299 so the eyes of each the eyes have it
unlock there must now be an election on
Tuesday the 15th of October
and I invite the right honourable
gentleman to respond to decide which of
us goes as prime minister to that
crucial Council on Thursday for 17th of
October I think it's very sad but MPs
have voted like this but if if I am
still Prime I do I think it's a great
dereliction of their democratic duty mr.
speaker mr. speaker we want an elections
we look forward to tapping this cupboard
out
I I barely say that I found these
exchanges quite predictable they've been
well rehearsed before we took place I do
think the Prime Minister's greatest
respect has a tremendous skill in
keeping a straight face while she's
being so disingenuous
[Applause]
and turn
[Music]
terms of the negotiation abomination the
way your party and given sympathy to me
about the problems that we have in the
Labor Party and you've just sat by
silently while your colleagues have been
marched out the eyes to the rights 298
the nose to 1156 the eyes have it but
the house will be aware that the motion
was not obtained the majority required
under the fixed term Parliament's Act
2011 a lot I think we will get some
resolution in the next few days because
Parliament is to to go into dissolution
next
[Music]